[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann für den
Sport einen schön guten abag von mir das
sind die nachrichtenthen von
heute vier Monate Krieg in narost die
Hamas legt einen Plan für eine
Waffenruhe von 135 Tagen vor und will in
der Zeit die elischen Geiseln
freilassen Arbeitskampf bei lufthanser
mehr als 100.000 Passagiere können nicht
fliegen weil das Bodenpersonal an fünf
Standorten streikt und Spannung pur im
Pokal Leverkusen schafft Last Minute sie
gegen starke Stuttgarter drittliges
sarbrücken hofft gegen Gladbach auf eine
Sensation befreit die Geiseln das ist
für viele Israelis das wichtigste
Kriegsziel nach vier Monaten
Ungewissheit g gestern Abend die
Nachricht der israelischen Armee von den
verbliebenen 136 Menschen in der Gewalt
der Terrorgruppe Hamas sind 31 tot
internationale Vermittler bemühen sich
weiter um eine Freilassung und eine
Feuerpause auf ihren jüngsten Vorschlag
reagierte die Hamas mit einem
Gegenvorschlag l
wepott Es ist ein weit verzweigtes
unterirdisches Labyrinth sagt die
israelische Armee in diesem Tunnel in
soll die Hamas 12 israelische Geiseln
zeitweise festgehalten haben über ihr
Schicksal wissen die Angehörigen wenig
mindestens 31 der mehr als 100 Männer
Frauen und Kinder sollen schon tot sein
die Zeit drängt usaußenminister blinken
beriet mit der israelischen Regierung
heute über die Antwort der Hamas auf
einen internationalen
vermittlervorschlag Freilassung der
verbliebenen Geiseln innerhalb von 125
Tagen aber gegen umfangreiche
Bedingungen unter anderem Einstellung
der Kämpfe
außerdem brauchen wir mehr
Hilfslieferungen für die leidende
Bevölkerung Notunterkünfte und den
kompletten Wiederaufbau der zerstörten
Infrastruktur daneben fordert Hamas auch
die Freilassung von 1500
palästinensischen Häftlingen aus
israelischen Gefängnissen man müsse die
Vorschläge prüfen so US außminister
blinken wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf
diese Arbeit und hoffen die Freilassung
der greiseln die im November
unterbrochen wurde bald wieder aufnehmen
zu
können eine Einstellung der Kämpfe lehnt
Regierungschef Netanyahu weiter ab nur
ein vollständiger Sieg schaffe
Sicherheit für
Israel nur weiterer militärischer Druck
wird die Geiseln befreien den
überzogenen Forderungen der Hamas
nachzugeben das wird nicht helfen im
Gegenteil es wird Grundlage für neue
Massaker
bieten nicht viel Spielraum verblinkten
der am Nachmittag palästinens Präsident
Abbas in ramala traf Demonstranten
fordern ein sofortiges Ende des Krieges
aber das ist nicht in Sicht die Gefechte
im Gazastreifen hielten auch heute
an Russland hat in der vergangenen Nacht
wieder mehrere ukrainische Städte mit
Raketen angegriffen in Kiev trafen die
Geschosse ein 18stöckiges Wohnhaus
allein in der Hauptstadt wurden durch
die Angriffe vier Menschen getötet und
mehr als 30 verletzt mindestens ein
weiteres Todesopfer gab es im
südukrainischen nikolajev auch dort
wurden Wohngebäude zerstört schwer
beschädigt außerdem das Gasnetz und
Wasserleitungen die ukrainische Armee
braucht dringend mehr Soldaten das
Parlament hat heute über eine weitere
Mobilmachung gesprochen und über höhere
Strafen für diejenigen die sich dem
Kriegsdienst entziehen wollen Anne Brühl
in Kiev wie stehen die Menschen dazu
nach fast Z Jahren
Krieg viele er hier sind erschöpft
irgendwie auch kriegsmüde und dennoch
entschlossen ihr Land weiter gegen den
russischen Aggressor zu verteidigen und
innerhalb dieser Parameter bewegt sich
auch die Diskussion um dieses Gesetz das
heute in erster Lesung durchs Parlament
gegangen ist im Kern geht es um die
Frage wer wird eingezogen und für wie
lange da gibt es jetzt ein bisschen mehr
Klarheit das wehralter wird herabgesetzt
von 27 auf 25 Jahre die Dienstzeit soll
begrenzt werden auf 36 Monate es sind
auch Ausnahmen vorgesehen für
Alleinerziehende z.B für Menschen mit
Beeinträchtigungen wer sich dem allen
entziehen will dem drohen in der Tat
Strafen über die dann Gerichte
entscheiden müssen eins ist wichtig die
Diskussion hier im Parlament die wird
weitergehen es wird vermutlich auch
Änderungen geben aber klare transparente
Regeln die sind vielen Ukrainern wichtig
denn eins ist auch klar dieses Land
steht militärisch im Moment sehr schwer
da und das liegt auch an der Zahl der
Soldaten vielen Dank für diese
Information live aus Kiev Anne Brühl war
das wer ist für die Sprengstoffanschläge
auf die nordstream Pipelines in der
Ostsee verantwortlich das ist nach wie
vor unklar Schweden hat jetzt seine
Ermittlungen eingestellt die schwedische
Justiz sei für die Vorfälle im September
2022 nahe der Insel Bornholm nicht
zuständig erklärte die Staatsanwalt aft
man habe Beweisstücke an deutsche
Behörden weitergegeben in Deutschland
und auch in Dänemark laufen die
Ermittlungen noch durch die Pipelines
war 10 Jahre lang russisches Gas
geliefert
worden kann Deutschland den Anschlag auf
die Pipeline aufklären das fragt ZDF
heute live und spricht unter anderem mit
einem Experten für den Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur um 19:30 uh wie immer in
der ZDF heute App und auf unseren Social
Media
Kanälen welche Tücken schärfere Gesetze
haben können zeigt sich manchmal erst in
der Praxis ein besonders krasses
Beispiel dafür ist der Bereich
sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder vor
dre Jahren wurden die Strafen für
herstellen und Weiterleiten von
Bildmaterial deutlich erhöht das trifft
nur leider auch die die helfen wollen
z.B Eltern oder Lehrer heute beschloss
das Kabinett das Gesetz zu korrigieren
Britta
spiermann es ist der Fall einer besorg
Mutter die ins Visier der Ermittler
geriet ihre zehnjährige Tochter hatte in
einem Chat eine Fotomontage entdeckt von
Kindergesichtern mit nackten
unterkörpern die Mutter leitete das Bild
weiter weil sie warnen wollte ich habe
eine E-Mail an die Eltern des Jungen
geschrieben der das Bild in den
klassenchat gestellt hat und habe beide
Klassenlehrer in Kopie gesetzt damit
hatte sich die Mutter strafbar gemacht
ihr drohte mindestens ein Jahr
Freiheitsstrafe von tausenden sogar
zehtausenden Fällen dieser Art spricht
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann er will
jetzt den Erwerb den Besitz und die
Verbreitung von sogenanntem
kinderpornographischenem Material von
einem Verbrechen auf ein Vergehen wieder
runterstufen ich will noch einmal ganz
klar sagen damit ist in keiner Weise
irgendeine
Relativierung dieses schlimmen Delikts
in irgendeiner Form verbunden
unverändert bleibt die maximale
Strafhöhe von bis zu 10 Jahren
Freiheitsstrafe erst 2021 war das
Strafrecht durch seine SPD Vorgängerin
verschärft worden und hatte zu einer
Überlastung der Behörden geführt zuletzt
ermittelte die Polizei in über der
Hälfte der Fälle gegen Minderjährige und
Eltern damit wurden Polizei
Staatsanwaltschaften und Gerichte
blockiert blieb weniger Zeit für
wirkliche Täter der Mutter wurde der
Prozess gemacht sie wurde nur zu einer
Geldstrafe verurteilt weil das Gericht
keine höere Strafe verhängen wollte in
Zukunft besteht die Möglichkeit in
bestimmten Fällen Verfahren auch wieder
einzustellen ob Mietverträge oder
Kredite Einschätzungen von der schufer
z.B haben weitreichende Folgen für
Verbraucher deren Rechte will die
Bundesregierung jetzt Stärken Name
Wohnadresse oder Daten aus sozialen
Netzwerken dürfen danach künftig nicht
mehr genutzt werden um die
Zahlungsfähigkeit einzuschätzen die
Regierung reagiert damit auf ein ur des
Europäischen
Gerichtshofs Europa arbeitet an der
Energiewende doch die hängt auch davon
ab ob die notwendige Technik verfügbar
ist Solarmodule beispielsweise kommen
weltweit zu 80% aus China mit einem
neuen Gesetz will die EU nun erreichen
dass mehr klimaneutrale Technologien in
Europa produziert werden helfen sollen
einfachere
Genehmigungsverfahren und bei
öffentlichen Ausschreibungen entscheidet
nicht nur der Preis ob das für die
gebeutelte deutsche Solarbranche reicht
berichtet Anja Charle beim
Solarmodulhersteller solarwad in Dresden
läuft die Produktion Verhalten dabei ist
der Bedarf enorm nur bietet China seine
Module mit Milliarden subventioniert zu
dampingpreisen an für die deutschen
Produzenten ein ruinöser Wettbewerb so
erwegt auch Solarwatt den
Produktionszweig mit 120 Mitarbeitern zu
schließen einen Seite
asiatische Produkte die zumindestens mal
im Preis schwer nachvollziehbar sind
wenn man wenn man schaut wie
Herstellkosten sind auf der anderen
Seite Amerika grenzenicht macht weil sie
eben diese Produkte nicht mehr ins Land
lassen dann sind das
Wettbewerbsbedingungen die einfach
einfach nicht mehr equal sind nicht mehr
fair sind und da können wir auch mit
guten Produkten in dieser Komponente
nicht dauerhaft gegenhalten das was die
EU plant schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren für neue Fabriken
dass öffentliche Ausschreibungen nicht
mehr vom preisabhängig sein sollen das
wird nicht reichen fürchten sie in
Sachsen und auch wann der Bund die
deutsche Solarindustrie unterstützen
will z.B mit einem käuferbonus ist noch
unklar wann es genau kommt kann ich i
noch nicht sagen aber das soll zeitnah
erfolgen was immer das auch heißen mag
bei der Energiewende ist China
unverzichtbar doch man wollte sich
unabhängiger machen in der EU in
Deutschland ökonomen warnen diese Frage
zu unterschätzen Gefahr besteht dass man
halt sich geopolitisch dann eben
abhängig macht von nur einem Lieferland
dass man möglicherweise erpressbar wird
gegenüber anderen Ländern und
möglicherweise besteht auch die Gefahr
dass eben die so technologischen
Vorsprung den wir derzeit noch haben bei
zumindest bei bei Solarzellen dass
dieser dann eben auch verloren ginge in
Sachsen könnten drei
Solarmodulhersteller die Produktion
schließen Solar wat will im zweiten
Halbjahr
entscheiden bei der lufthans geh heute
kaum was in Frankfurt München Hamburg
Berlin und Düsseldorf wird gestreikt das
Bodenpersonal hat die Airline weitgehend
lahm gelegt auch die umbuchungsschalter
waren wegen des Streiks nicht besetzt 27
Stunden noch bis morgen früh soll der
Ausstand dauern werdis Nadelstich gegen
die lufthanser trifft zetausende
Passagiere Stefan Schlösser
berichtet Flüge gekenzelt Schalter
geschlossen ein Anblick den kein
Reisender gerne sieht bis 90% der
geplanten lufthanserverbindungen fallen
hier am Frankfurter Flughafen aus andere
Airlines sind aber nicht betroffen wir
fliegen nach Kuba mit Kondor und laut
unseren Informationen soll es klappen es
ist für uns natürlich unkomfortabel weil
wir reisen jetzt vi Stunden länger aber
gut wir kommen trotzdem da man ist
langsam genervt definitiv an fünf
Standorten streigt heute das
Bodenpersonal der Lufthansa darunter die
Drehkreuze Frankfurt und München
bundesweit fallen Flüge aus 100000
Reisende sind betroffen die Gewerkschaft
fordert 12,5% mehr Gehalt mindestens
aber 500 € bei 12 Monaten Laufzeit unser
wichtigstes Anliegen ist dass bei der
lufthanser weder endlich wieder
Vergütungen gezahlt werden die zeitgemäß
sind dass die lufthanser noch die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom Morgen
findet weil viele Passagiere die
vielleicht jetzt auch frustriert sind
wegen des Streiks sie erleben ja
tagtäglich dass die lufthanser nicht
mehr funktioniert weil das personalf das
Unternehmen bietet bisher % für 3 Jahre
hier stört man sich vor allem am
Zeitpunkt des Streiks die Verhandlungen
hätten doch gerade erst begonnen eine
Eskalation zu einem derartig frühen
Zeitpunkt nach nur zwei Treffen wo man
erstmal gegenseitig die Sicht auf die
Dinge erklärt hat das ist aus meiner
Sicht unnötig und
unverhältnismäßig gestreikt wird noch
bis morgen früh kommende Woche soll dann
weiterverhandelt
werden das verheerende Erdbeben in der
Türkei und Syrien vor einem Jahr hat das
humanitäre Leid der Menschen gerade im
Nordwesten Syriens verschlimmert denn
dort in der Provinz idlip in der
islamistische Rebellen herrschen gibt es
seit Jahren große Not und Gewalt durch
das assadreime es kommt nur wenig
internationale Hilfe an für die Menschen
dort heißt das noch mehr Armut und noch
mehr Hunger Gine
atai es sind die letzten hilfsrationen
die verteilt werden im Dezember hatte
das un welternährungs Programm das Ende
sein Lebensmittelhilfen angekündigt das
internationale Spendenaufkommen für
Syrien war noch nie so niedrig die Not
und der Hunger noch nie so groß Mariam
jehja lebt seit dem Erdbeben im
vergangenen Jahr im Zelt seit dem Beben
hat sie ein
Nervenleiden sie sagten mir das sei das
letzte Paket als ich das hörte war ich
geschockt wie soll ich weiterleben
normalerweise verkaufe ich die Hälfte
dieser Lebensmittel um meine Medikamente
zu kaufen ohne das spendenpaket kann ich
mir keine Medizin mehr
leisten Winterregen und Minusgrade
besonders die mehr als 800.000
Vertriebenen die in Zelten leben müssen
leiten darunter so etwas wie einen
Wiederaufbau nach dem Beben haben die
Menschen hier nicht gesehen nur eine
Krise nach der anderen
iptisam lebt mit ihrer Familie immer
noch in ihrem seitdem Beben
abbruchreifen Haus keine einzige
internationale Organisation habe sie je
besucht sagt
sie ich habe mit den eigenen Händen
versucht das Dach abzustützen wie eine
Ertrinkende die sich an den letzten
Strohalm klammert wir brauchen Hilfe wir
sind in einer
Katastrophe durch das Erdbeben hat sich
ein Flussbett verschoben die Bauern am
oronttisfluss leiden regelmäßig unter
den Überschwemmungen sie haben ganze
Ernten
verloren während die wel auf Gaza
blickte nutzten syriens Machthaber Assad
und sein verbündeteer Russland die
vergangenen Monate um hunderte von
zivilen Zielen in nordwestsyrien
anzugreifen als
ölreicher Handelspartner ist
Aserbaidschan für Europa immer wichtiger
geworden heute will sich
Langzeitpräsident aliev die nächste
Amtszeit sichern 6 Millionen Menschen
sind in Aserbaidschan im Südkaukasus zur
Wahl aufgerufen gewählt wird auch in der
Region Bergkarabach die im vergangenen
Herbst zurückerobert wurde ein Erfolg
für den autoritärregierenden Präsidenten
von dem er sich viele Stimmen verspricht
Sebastian
berichtet
jaavitnabieev ist ganz nah dran an der
Wahl in Baku er wurde zwar von der
Regierung als Wahlbeobachter ausgewählt
nimmt aber seinen Job sehr ernst er will
Verstöße aufdecken mehrfach hatte heute
schon welche beobachtet manche Menschen
hätten mehrfach abgestimmt bei anderen
sei die Registrierung nicht korrekt
abgelaufen doch sobald er der
Wahlkommission diese Verstöße melden
will bekommt er
Probleme es ist schwierig als
Wahlbeobachter zu arbeiten jede
Anmerkung die wir machen und jeder
Kommentar hat eine harsche Gegenreaktion
zur Folge wir wurden mehrfach damit
bedroht dass sie die Polizei rufen uns
anzeigen und uns
rausschmeißen der autokratische
Präsident ilam aliev gibt heute seine
Stimme symbolisch in der eroberten
Hauptstadt Berg karabachs ab alle Welt
soll sehen er hat hier jetzt das Sagen
in Baku sind die Wahllokale heute gut
besucht laut offiziellen Stellen haben
bis zum frühen Abend über 70% ihre
Stimme abgegeben erwartet wird ein
deutlicher Sieg von ilam
maliev es gab keinen nennenswerten
Wahlkampf oder einen ernstzunehmenden
Gegenkandidaten die Opposition wurde
über Jahre gezielt geschwächt und im
Vorfeld der Wahlen wurden Journalisten
festgenommen die zur Korruption der
Präsidentenfamilie recherchiert hatten
deswegen bezweifeln Experten dass diese
Wahl frei und unabhängig ist am Abend
feiern alievs Fans in Baku bereits
seinen Wahlsieg ersten Umfragen zufolge
kann der Präsident mit über 90% der
Stimmen
rechnen einen Tag vor der Parlamentswahl
in Pakistan hat es zwei Bombenanschläge
auf wahlkampfbüros gegeben dabei kam
mindestens 29 Menschen ums Leben mehrere
Dutzend wurden verletzt die
Sicherheitslage in Pakistan ist seit
Monaten an gespannt immer wieder kommt
es zu Anschlägen verantwortlich dafür
sind die terrormiliz islamischer Staat
die pakistanischen Taliban sowie
separatistengruppen in den USA haben
Unfallermittler erste Erkenntnisse zur
beinahe Katastrophe einer Boeing 737 MAX
9 vorgestellt Anfang Januar war mitten
im Flug ein Stück Bordwand
herausgebrochen demnach fehlten offenbar
vier wichtige Bolzen diese sollten
sicherstellen dass das Bauteil fest mit
dem Rumpf verbunden ist die Maschine der
Alaska Airlines mit mehr als 170
Menschen an Bord befand sich in 5 km
Höhe als das Unglück passierte verletzt
wurde dabei niemand die Maschine konnte
notlanden und jetzt der Sport Biathlon
WM mäßiger Auftakt aus deutscher Sicht
bei mäßigem Wetter noch ja Wind Wärme
und Regen im tschechischen noviesto die
deutsche mixstaffel in der ersten Hälfte
noch auf Medaillenkurs am Ende der 4 x 6
km aber reicht es nur für den fünften
Platz für Franziska preus konnte die
Enttäuschung kaum größer sein als erste
nach den beiden Männern strele und
navrad ins Rennen gegangen reichten ihr
vor 20 000 nassgeregneten Zuschauern im
Stehendanschlag auch alle drei Nachlader
nicht um die Strafrunde zu vermeiden der
anschließende Stolperer ein Sinnbild für
einen gebrauchten
Tag ja irgendwie mir lat reingeschossen
und ich schon in schiand Einlauf oder so
ein schiand rein war ich schon extrem
angespannt die neuen mixtweltmeister
kommen aus Frankreich vor Norwegen und
Schweden die deutsche Schlussläuferin
Vanessa Vogt kommt als fünfte über die
Ziellinie zum DFB Pokal gestern Abend
Viertelfinale Leverkusen gegen Stuttgart
ein suerspiel beide Teams voll auf
Augenhöhe Bayern mit dem Siegtreffer
erst in der 90
Minute Jonathan das Stuttgarter aus in
Leverkusen auch dank Florian Wirz dessen
präzise Flanke kurz vor Schluss TS
Kopfball zum 3:2 vorausgeht in der 58
Minute geht Stuttgart mit dem 2:1 durch
Chris fürüich zum zweiten Mal in Führung
8 Minuten später gleicht Amin Adli
erneut aus der Siegtreffer von jonalanar
in der 90 Minute beendet das 30
Leverkusener Pflichtspiel der Saison
ohne Niederlage am Samstag erwartet der
Bundesliga Tabellenführer Verfolger
Bayern München zum
Heimspiel ja und das letzte
Viertelfinale das beginnt gleich
pokalschreck sabrücken gegen Gladbach
Katrin Müller hohnenstein in salbrücken
Stimmung gut aber Wetter schlecht
jaarbeit es hat den ganzen Tag geregnet
es sind tapfere Menschen seit anderthalb
Stunden damit beschäftigt mit laubläsern
den Platz irgendwie trocken zu bekommen
dann kam die Schiedsrichter haben das
Ballverhalten auf dem Platz überprüft
Ergebnis man will das Aufwärmen der
Mannschaften abwarten und dann
entscheiden ob dieses Spiel füffen
werden kann die Fans sind weitgehend
unbeeindruckt davon es gab einen
fanmarsch durch die Stadt und natürlich
ist die Hoffnung groß dass eine nächste
Pokalsensation gelingt gegen die Bayern
gegen Eintracht Frankfurt hat das ja
schon ganz gut geklappt und natürlich
hoffen alle dass dieses Pokalspiel heute
hier stattfinden kann danke Katrin wir
sehen uns gleich wieder sarbrücken gegen
Gladbach live im ZDF ab 20:15 Uhr soen
Wetter ja hoffentlich findet überhaup
statt das Spiel also müssen wir mal
gucken ne und jetzt noch ein Foto das
den Publikumspreis des Londoner
Naturkundemuseums gewonnen hat auf der
Inselgruppe Spitzbergen kam einem Briten
dieses Motiv vor die Linse der Eisbär
habe sich mit seinen Tatzen ein Bett im
Eis bereitet friedlich aber auch fragil
wegen der Erderwärmung gibt's immer
weniger solche eisbetten für
eisbeären fehlt noch das Lotto die
Gewinnzahlen lauten
18 15 19
31 und die Superzahl 0 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZF Text auf Seite
557 viel Regen im Westen Schnee und
Schneematsch im Norden und Osten
weiterhin mild im Süden das
Wettergeschehen sortiert gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal mit Dunja
Hayali sehen sie wohl in der
Halbzeitpause gegen 21:35 Uhr wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
bis morgen wenn sie Mö auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend am westlichen
Bildrand kommt hier tief Pauline heran
und das beschäftigt uns nicht nur morgen
sondern auch am Freitag mit Regen und
mit Schnee heute Nacht ziehen die
Schneefälle hier in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen ostwärts ab aber auch
über Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg
vorpomn ziehen einige Schneeschauer
hinweg in Süddeutschland fällt nur Regen
und es kann glatt werden auf den Straßen
in Norddeutschland denn dort sinken die
Werte auf 0 bis -3° sonst bleibt die
Nacht milder und morgen ziehen dann neue
Regen und Schneefälle von Westen heran
so Schneid es dann in
nordrehein-westfalen in Niedersachsen
Hessen sachsenanhall Thüringen und
Sachsen sehr viel von dem Schnee wird
nicht liegen bleiben aber für
Schneematsch auf Straßen und Gehwegen
wird's reichen im Süden lässt der Regen
nach und im Nordosten kommen Regen und
Schnee noch gar nicht an das liegt dort
auch am Ostwind die Temperaturen liegen
morgen in Norddeutschland bei kühlen
Werten nämlich nur so 3 bis 5° sonst
wird's milder mit bis zu 14° und
spannend wird dann auf jeden Fall noch
mal der Freitag da gibt's nämlich
Schneeregen im Nordosten bei
Höchsttemperaturen von nur 2° im
Südwesten wird's dagegen schon mild mit
bis zu 17° am Samstag gibt's die 17° mit
föenunterstützung am Alpenrand guten
Abend